our next story takes us to Idaho where
doomsday call Mom Lori valo day Bell is
gearing up for trial this week each
party submitted their proposed jury
instructions giving us a potential
glimpse into each of their cases jury
selection for valos starts in just about
two weeks she faces murder grand theft
and conspiracy charges in the depths of
her two children J.J valo and Tyler Ryan
she is also charged with the death of
Tammy Debo the ex-wife of her husband
Chad Dabo
he will be tried separately on similar
charges according to the state's
proposed instructions they allege that
Lori Chad and Laurie's late brother Alex
Cox conspired to murder Laurie's
children along with Tammy the state
believes the murders were justified by
the family through their religious
beliefs as well as a collection of
Social Security money the defense has
proposed instructions Focus heavily on
the fact that feelings and opinions
don't equal guilt and the defendant is
innocent until proven guilty we spoke
with a jury consultant who explained key
themes the attorneys should focus on
when picking a jury here's what she had
to say but they have to explore is her
mental health issues this has been a
very big thing that's been on the table
for a long time you know was she
mentally ill and that's the thing is
that everybody's wondering and also was
that mental illness one of such
magnitude that would have caused her to
create such a heinous offense against
Minister children that's what the the
defense is stating they're stating that
she was mentally ill that you know Viola
has taken her over that has talked her
into killing her children and uh so so
then that kind of brings you into those
religious beliefs right so this is kind
of that strange offspring that cult
offspring of the Mormon religion which
is not your traditional Mormon belief so
I think that the the religious beliefs
are going to be a big one especially
where this is located right so the other
thing too is this premeditation that's
also another big one on here those
mitigating factors was this something
that was premeditated
so Bernard I think you you kind of hit
the nail on the head as well the
proposed question seemed a little light
and there were like three or four main
topics but what does that tell you about
what the focus is on this case
exactly the proposed jury instructions
as I saw it it's not really going to the
heart of the matter in order when you're
focusing on jury on selecting the jury
you want to make sure that the jury that
you select are jurors that can be fair
and impartial and meaning that the
jurors don't have already a
predetermined decision as to the guilt
of of Miss fallow so in determining that
you have to ask questions what is their
mind frame what do they think about
certain issues and that is something
that we're not seeing now I think the
defense may just have to go with look
the prosecution's not proven a case
Beyond a reasonable doubt that there are
holes in this case but I don't know if
they're really going to go much into the
mental state of Lori valo in order to
try to get an acquitto in this case I
mean Nema I would have thought that I
would have seen questions like what do
you think about cults at the end of days
children being killed parents accused of
killing children should we expect those
types of questions in the jury selection
process
I agree Brian and I also agree with
Bernard I mean I'm excited for this case
it's a very sad case but I thought we'd
be hearing about Armageddon the zombie
apocalypse we're all supposed to be dead
by now so this is a very unique case you
gotta tailor your jury instructions the
facts of this case especially when at
least it may be a capital case with
respect to Chad dabel of course the
prosecution botched their Discovery
obligations so the death penalties off
the table with respect to Lori yeah
maybe a juror believes in the end of
days and they're just doing this jury
selection till then or maybe they think
this is completely crazy you'll never
know but we'll see well while the death
penalty won't be an option for Lori valo
Idaho lawmakers are making it easier for
convicted criminals to die by firing
squad a bill was approved on Monday with
a veto proof majority and it's now in
the hands of State Governor Brad little
if the bill is signed death by firing a
squad will only be used as a backup plan
in two scenarios one if Idaho cannot get
access to drugs used in Lethal
Injections and two if legal and action
is deemed unconstitutional by a court a
fiscal note included in the bill says it
will cost nearly eight hundred thousand
dollars to meet the appropriate
requirements for firing squad executions
the most recent state to allow firing
squad executions with South Carolina
which passed a bill last March
and in other news a Georgia man recently
won the right to move forward with a
lawsuit against the state because he
wants to be put to death by firing squad
Michael Wade Nance has been on death row
since 2002. he was convicted of
murdering a man while fleeing a bank
robbery Nan sued the Georgia Department
of Corrections in 2020 saying Lethal
Injections would Mount to torture which
would violate his constitutional rights
Nance claims his regular use of a
medicine for back pain would make his
brain less responsive to a sedative
given during lethal injection a Georgia
judge is now overseeing the matter
attorneys for the retired eye doctors
suing celebrity Gwyneth Paltrow are
laying out the changes their client
experience after a ski slope collision
with the actress left him with a brain
injury it happened seven years ago at
Deer Valley Resort in Park City Utah
Paltrow and Terry Sanderson who's now in
his 70s were traveling down a slope at
the same time one of them crashed into
the other and each says the other one is
at fault while Paltrow had some minor
injuries from the Collision Sanderson
had multiple broken ribs and that brain
injury we mentioned well Sanderson then
filed a lawsuit in 2019 and Paltrow
countersued he's seeking at least three
hundred thousand dollars in damages on a
negligence claim in her countersuit
Paltrow is requesting just one dollar in
Damages and for Sanderson to cover her
legal fees one of sanderson's daughters
testify Thursday the attorney asked her
how her father changed after the 2016
accident
before you could he could have lots
going on and now it's very A to B
A to B don't throw in a c or a d right
because then we're gone completely so
how do we simplify you know and just
just those task just
um A to B you know maybe take it as kind
of a a gift to be in the present with
what you're doing right now
you know just let's just focus on this
one step and I think that's easy for me
to try to say how do we move forward
because but I understand that there's a
lot of grief and loss for the way that
his life functioned before that it
doesn't function now
all right I'm joined by two special
guests today former prosecutor and trial
attorney Bernardo villalona and former
Federal prosecutor Nima Romani so Nema
let's start with you how do we know
these personality changes I think this
is what the defenses or what Paltrow's
attorneys are getting at were really
caused by the ski Collision how does a
plaintiff prove that
Brian we don't know and brain injuries
they're invisible injuries so we know
Paltrow's attorney they're attacked in
this case on two bases liability of
course who was who had the right away
and who was lower down the slope but
also damages we know that brain injuries
those are invisible injuries so that's
where the neuropsych testing that's
where the medical doctors come in that's
where the family members loved ones come
and talk about memory issues cognitive
difficulties but it's not like an
orthopedic injury there's not going to
be an X-Ray there's not going to be an
MRI usually a positive MRI whether it's
a brain or a CT so it's going to really
be up to those medical and late
witnesses to prove the brain injury in
this case yeah embroidery it's been
seven years since this Collision
happened do you do you think the jury is
taking that into account in any way
I think at some point the jury does have
that question be in the back of their
demo sense of why are we just not
hearing about this case in 2023 but you
should remember that the judge will
probably give an instruction as to the
timing of it you have to also think that
we went through the covid-19 pandemic
and that pretty much set down the
justice system it shut down the
courthouses so cases weren't being tried
and cases weren't moving at all so
that's also a reason for the delay in
this case but we still have the few
years before the pandemic that nothing
was going on but they're hearing about
it now yeah well we'll see how the jury
handles out of course we'll keep eyes on
the Paltrow case with Anderson and an
important update for you now on a Case
we've actually been following Jennifer
and James crumbly parents of the
Michigan school shooter can go to trial
on involuntary manslaughter charges the
crumblers are both facing four counts of
involuntary manslaughter after their son
opened fire inside a high school killing
four students prosecutors say that
parents should have known that their son
was experienced mental health problems
and should not have bottom a gun they
point out that the crumblies were
alerted by School staff that their son
was struggling and his parents chose to
send him back to class he committed the
shooting later that day the defense says
charging the parents is an overreach but
the appeals court affirmed the lower
Court's decision that the parents could
be bound over for trial
we also have an update on a case of a
Microsoft executive gunned down in a
targeted attack in Florida the suspect
Mario Salado Saldana Fernandez appeared
before a judge for the first time police
believe Hernandez was involved in a
scheme to kill his new wife's ex-husband
the alleged triggerman Henry tennan
agreed to plead guilty and testify
against any accomplices Fernandez
appeared in court to hear the charges
against him which include first-degree
murder police say Jared brigagon had
just dropped off his twins at their
mother's home and was headed back to his
own place with his two-year-old in the
car when he came across a tire in the
road he got out of the he got out to
move it please say then tendon shot him
an exact motive has not yet been
released
still had a long